elles sont jeunes âgés et migrantes ou
autochtone elles ont pris les rues de
montréal gatineau québec trois-rivières
et cacouna pour la cinquième marche
mondiale des femmes
elle dénonce principalement la violence
contre les femmes mais surtout contre
les femmes autochtones quand les deux
potes ce qui veut dire les femmes
autochtones et les femmes non
autochtones se met en mouvement les
gouvernements prendront plus au sérieux
peut être pas assez pour reconnaître le
racisme systémique tant et aussi
longtemps que le gouvernement pour nier
que dura systémique mais c'est qu'on
laisse exercer ses formes
de violentes c'est pas juste un mot
quand vous en êtes victime quand il ya
des gens qui décèdent des femmes qui
meurent à cause de ça c'est pas juste un
mot c'est une réalité que des gens
vivent au quotidien je pense qu'on l'a
entendu clairement pantone reconnaître
leurs astuces system seller demande est
légitime
c'est elle qui vivent ça c'est elle qui
en meurent c'est elle qui en souffre
les marcheuses dénonce aussi les
féminicides on en compte 16 depuis le
début de l'année ok en meurent combien
d'autres pour que vous preniez
conscience que des femmes se font tuer
parce qu'elles sont des femmes québec a
confirmé l'octroi d'une aide d'urgence
pour compris la violence conjugale il ya
eu beaucoup de mesure d'annoncer dans
les derniers mois je pense qu'il faut
donner le temps à ces mesures-là d'agir
elles étaient donc des centaines au
québec à s'unir le système judiciaire
pour la violence conjugale pour l'allier
harcèlement sexuel 6 7 ans et j'ai vécu
malheureusement beaucoup de
harcèlement de rue harcèlement moral
l'insécurité contre la violence la
violence conjugale pour l'équité pour
l'égalité des femmes les hommes et cette
artiste qui trimballe une planète
rappelle que les femmes donnent la vie
comme la terre il faut donc prendre soin
des deux ici marie josée paquet comme
radio canada montréal